even the power of all six Infinity
stones combined has its limits
so declared Avengers endgame
screenwriters Christopher Markus and
Stephen McFeely
in a recent sit-down with the New York
Times addressing the heart-wrenching
death of one of the MC yous
longest-tenured characters fair warning
we'll be discussing spoilers from here
on on a quest to the Past to recover the
soul stone from the planet Vermeer
before it was acquired by Thanos Clint
Barton and Natasha Romanov find
themselves faced with the same conundrum
as the mad Titan in Avengers infinity
war to possess the stone you must lose
that which you love in a heartbreaking
illustration of the pair's bond they end
up actually fighting each other each
determined to be the one to go over the
cliff to their deaths so that the other
can complete the mission in the end the
Black Widow prevails and plunges to her
doom on the planets rocky Beach leaving
a distraught Hawkeye wailing to the
heavens with the glowing stone in hand
The Times asked Markus and McFeely why
did Black Widow have to die Bruce Banner
used the power of the Tony Stark built
Infinity Gauntlet to bring back all of
the heroes who perished in infinity Wars
decimation why could he not bring her
back as well
this is monsters and magic and nothing
we were ever trained for the writers
offered a little insight into their
thought process and dealing with the
death of a founding Avenger the only
woman on the original team mcfeely says
her journey in our minds had come to an
end if she could get the Avengers back
she comes from such an abusive terrible
mind-control background so when she gets
to voir Mir and she has a chance to get
the family back that's a thing she would
trade for but do the other characters
and the audience get a chance to mourn
such a central character McFeely says
that was a huge challenge for the
writing duo Marcus adds Tony Stark gets
a funeral Natasha doesn't that's partly
because Tony's this massive public
figure and she's been a cipher the whole
time it wasn't necessarily honest to the
character to give her a funeral the
biggest question about it is what Thor
erases there on the dock we have the
Infinity stones why don't we just bring
her back the answer lies in the very
nature of the soul stone and the trade
that it demands McFeely makes it clear
that bringing back Natasha would mean
giving up the stone apparently if Banner
had concentrated with single-minded
focus on resurrecting Romanoff
he may have sealed the fate of literally
everyone else by giving up the soul
stone negating the noble sacrifice she
had made the writers also revealed that
an early version of the script had
Hawkeye not black widow making the
sacrifice but the impassioned plea of a
member of end Gabe's crew changed their
minds McFeely said Jen under Dolph our
visual effects producer read an outline
or draft where Hawkeye goes over and she
said don't you take this away from her I
actually get emotional thinking about it
we're still friends right
in the MC use timeline
Earth's Mightiest Heroes will be black
widow less going forward but that won't
stop mighty Marvel from looking into the
past after being promised for years
black widow is finally getting her own
solo film which is currently in
production and will focus on the future
Avengers early years and recruitment by
shield the film's official synopsis
reveals that the flick will take place
15 years after the fall of the Soviet
Union which would put it right around
2006 before the Iron Man armor was even
a gleam in Tony Stark's eye Johansson
will reprise her role and the flick also
boasts the Red Hot Florence pew David
Harbour and Rachel vice among its cast
Ozzie director Kate Shortland is set to
helm the picture from a script by Jack
Schaeffer who contributed to the
screenplay for Captain Marvel and we'll
run the vision and Scarlet Witch limited
series for Disney Plus so while the only
true family she's ever known may have
seen the last of Romanov the viewing
audience has not Black Widow is expected
to be the first film of the MC use phase
4 which raises another intriguing
question how will its events figure into
whatever grand overarching narrative
Marvel Studios has planned next we can't
wait to find out tend to see Scarlett
Johansson suit up as our favorite
Russian super spy at least one more time
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the Avengers are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]